So the way that we deal with this problem
is actually exactly like we did when we
were doing 10-(2+3), but this time we
can't change what's inside the
parenthesis. There's no way that we know
of to simplify x+9, since these are not
like terms. So that means, that we can't
go about doing things with the first
method of PEMDAS, or at least the p here
doesn't affect the way that we can do the
problem, since we can't change what's
inside the parenthesis. So, that means
we're stuck with this second method.
Remember down here that meant applying the
negative sign to both the 2 and the 3 so
we ended up subtracting each of them from
the 10. So let's try to do the same thing
up here. We want to subtract both the X
and also the 9 so we'll have 4 minus X and
then also minus 9. Rearrange and then
combine like terms 4-9 is -5-x so we have
our final answer of -5-x.